huh all right guys we're live we're back
live again i don't know what happened
i think that i think it was because i'm
not supposed to tell you guys where to
go
to uh support
i i may be wrong about that
i don't know if i got baited into that
but i learned something maybe that's
what maybe that's why i don't know
i don't know if it's the thumbnail man
no alex it's not the internet
we got that fiber fiber here in town
that was weird though i hope it saved
the video
big brother's always listening
john malcolm thinks it's because of the
thumbnail
i don't think so i don't know man we got
cut off really quick like right as i was
saying that
we got cut off yeah i hope i can salvage
it i hope it's
salvageable man
stop violating youtube's terms
that was weird yeah well thanks for
joining back guys
so i'm just adding leg detail here
and we have to connect these in some
sort of way
so we could probably do that by like
getting one of these leg pieces
and just extending it
something like that i don't know
i like it i like that it's not
completely linear too
yeah or we could just stretch this one
all the way out
and scoot it over that was cool too
yeah like that's pretty sweet
and then you can even just duplicate
this and get some like little tiny wires
coming out
something like that i dig it i think
this works a lot better too because now
we're out in a different negative space
we're not messing with more wires yeah
agreed you don't want to confuse the
silhouette
yeah that's pretty that's pretty cool
awesome okay i mean that's that's a vibe
for sure
don't run off again oh my god thank you
euclid i appreciate you man
that's funny oh boy is that jack black
that face i don't know no it's when he's
in the lego
or no he's not the lego it's when he's
like trying to blow out that candle
remember in a sock have you seen that
japanese game show where jack black is
like
trying to blow out a candle but he's
he's in a uh
a stocking like a woman's stocking and
he's like
i think i've seen it that's what it
looks like i'll look it up um that looks
pretty cool man
yeah i like it so what we can do is we
can take this in photoshop and like
do a bunch of different passes and you
know spend an hour or two
tweaking it and getting it right but i
think it's time
to move on because i just want to
announce
the winners of the weekly challenge i
think that's i think that's where we're
at
um actually before i before i say that
before i even utter those words
it's already too late um
are you happy with this vibe minus like
some photoshop uh some photoshopping
where we're going to just like push and
pull
some light a little bit and like maybe
tweak the color and stuff yes
and then if you're just saying that for
the stream then we can always you know
say afterwards too or just like you know
this is
i'm very happy okay
but let's do the weekly challenge here
um i'm going to take
a one-minute break and i'll come right
back and we're going to break down we're
going to go through
all the submissions the theme was
christmas this year
um and so people put out a bunch of like
christmas themed renders
and uh i can't wait to see those yeah
yeah take a look
you just look do i get to look at these
renders yeah yeah if you want
absolutely um yeah i'm gonna take a one
minute break casey if you wanna like
i don't know talk to these guys about
whatever if you've got questions for
casey
drop them right now because i'll be back
in a minute twice if clint is forcing
you to like the art
all right i'll be right back
hey everybody welcome to my podcast
what's my favorite instrument i don't
know man sometimes it's the uh the sum
of many instruments that i enjoyed the
most like orchestral music
so i don't know playing with color is
fun but if i had to pick just one i
think piano would be pretty easy
you know a lot of polyphony you can pull
off with that
a lot of really incredible piano
concertos where just the piano gets a
soul and it's insane
give us a smolder i don't think so how
old are you i don't know guess
how old do i look
where are you working uh i work for
myself i'm a self-employed composer
i work for people like clint or people
like capcom when i'm working on video
games and stuff like that
so yeah 19
28 28 28's the oldest anybody's ever
told me i look
12 yeah that's a little bit more
appropriate 29 11
15.
are we gonna get i don't think i don't
know if clint has the uh his audio set
up for a sneak peek but
we'll see we'll see we got to get
through these these christmas renders
did you for married i am married i am
married to my wife ali edwards who is
both an artist
uh in the animation industry as well as
a singer who works for people like mick
gordon
on killer instinct she's sung on doom
the video game and she also sang on
devil trigger for
devil may cry 5.
expert man you really like yeah man i
love blender
all the the cool video stuff and the the
rendering
stuff and the other words that i don't
know
where did you learn to make music in my
bedroom
growing up whether it was playing guitar
along to a cd or
[Music]
trying to copy some of my favorite
musicians
um or playing live somewhere yeah but
mostly in my bedroom
i'm good thank you
dude is it hard to get a job in the
music industry yeah i think it's hard to
get a job and
uh i i don't want to say in all the film
industry but it just really depends on
what you're trying to do especially with
composers though we don't have a union
we don't have a bunch of other stuff
that bolsters up it's all about
connections and who you know
so yeah oh time to stop pretending to be
clint
all right dude i'm just like
that sucks that did the video get
removed
i hope not i really hope not surely they
would just like clip it back
10 seconds and then let you have your
video i don't know
maybe start recording through uh obs to
be safe in the future
yeah i'm kind of sketched out now
all right
man maybe it was set to private
i hope
all right well i'm not gonna worry about
that right now i hope clint brought you
some good he didn't bring me any cookies
yeah we're still making them we're still
making those cookies
okay so let's do this let's talk about
the winners of
the christmas weekly challenge
this is the last stream of the year this
is also the last weekly challenge of the
year
um because i need a break i'm going
going home for christmas going back to
atlanta
and uh but yeah there was a uh there was
a lot
a lot of submissions here and we're
gonna do it live we're gonna go through
every single one
talk about what we like what we don't
like and uh
and then choose five winners because
five of you guys will be
will receive the weekly challenge roll
today and you're gonna have it through
the year because they only get updated
every time we do a new challenge so
oh yeah where do we begin
i'm pretty excited for this there's a
lot
dude there's a lot
oh my god right that's neon
okay here we go
that's neon still i think that's neon it
doesn't look like christmas to me
here we go christmas
so the first one comes from
johann thomas
johann thomas
this is pretty cool you know it looks
real looks real to me i actually see him
in the uh reflection of the bulb
or this like a little christmas ornament
here
i like your motion blur it's cool i like
your lighting that's not bad
looks like a good well-rendered tree
and there's the clay render here that's
crazy to me
i'm like i have no idea what you guys do
to do this but it's like magic
to me yeah it's super cool um
i don't i don't know if i have too many
negative things to say about it you know
it's a nice picture
i just don't know i don't know i'm not
i'm not going to say too much after that
i think it's well rendered and i think
the motion blur is nice and the fact
that you can see you taking the picture
is cool
i like that a lot let's keep going
so this one's by willy i really like
willie's style
this one here is taken to you know look
like it's part of like a film
film print here funny enough so
kodak portra 400 is actually negative
film
so you would see the negative here it is
not positive c41
film that's the nerdiest thing you
probably hear me say
actually
[Laughter]
um that's funny that looks really cool
too
but yeah i love this this is really
really nice in
then the lighting is kind of similar to
the lighting that we were doing today
yeah with our you know with our album
art here which that looks really cool
i'm glad that it turned out that looks
so cool yeah
all right there's your clay render
to prove that it wasn't done through
like a tutorial or something
because that's been done in the past but
moving on we got loon or
loon or i don't know how to pronounce
that but this is your christmas render
here
it's of like some anatomy looking guy
holding up a christmas tree
lit with some lights and it's pretty
sweet
very nice i like the dimly lit scene
here i think it's cool
um pretty christmasy you know holding a
christmas tree some red white green
stripes in the background it's pretty
subtle though
super subtle yeah the background that's
the only thing is like the background to
me feels a little too dark
um and i just kind of if i squint i just
see like this character which isn't the
worst thing you know if that's what
you're going for it's fine
um but it's a solid render so i think it
looks good
let's keep going doctor
all right so the first thing
that my first gripe i don't i don't see
christmas when i look at this
um so christmas is the theme
and so that makes it difficult you know
um i see cows i see grass i see like
rapunzel little castle looking thing
here but i don't
see christmas that's the only issue
it's a fine render you know center
composition uh you're giving a natural
vignette with the
leaves and stuff on the left and right
which is cool
but i'm just missing that christmas
that's the only thing
all right moving on putin
yeah got you with the among us
christmas themed episode here
uh this is fun man this is fun i like
the work that you put into this i think
this is
i think this is cool um different little
characters walking around having a good
time enjoying the snow we got a little
snowman hat
christmas tree hat it's a good time uh
in the city
um very nice very nice all right
what else do we got here
soul nate it's crisp
are you all right yes it's christmas on
the moon
all right um
not bad you know i i do i do miss a
little bit of the surface imperfections
here
and uh you know if my surface
imperfection pack was out now
you know you'd be able to pick that up
but that's going to be next week
um but yeah no this is cool i like the
way you actually have like the garland
around the
around this thing um i wonder if you're
using like command strips
what do you think like are you even
using command strips up here to
hook it up to the space center or you
just go on nails dude i hope you're not
using nails
you're getting like an airtight vacuum
oxygen sealed moon base
yeah you just imagine some gomer pile up
there going
just it'd be so bad oxygen dropping
yeah this is pretty cool i dig it
yeah i hope that's tape oh yeah just
straight up some tape
joshua this is nice man i like your
lighting here
very cool i like your composition
very very nice um i think the character
though is like it's a little like
there's some artifacting and some low
poly issues going on here like with the
arm the way the arms bent
that'd be messing with your weight
painting
so you'd have to adjust your weights
there
and then there's like a line hard line
here
on her cheek um
but you know it's not the worst
certainly not the worst popeye forearms
yeah that's some big old forearms but
yeah no this is not bad i like this i
like the lighting and everything
good work here
all right rico
santa's taking back what's his i guess
um
a little heavy on the chromatic
aberration here
um but it's not it's not the worst you
know
i think this is fun i like your center
framed vibes here
and you got the um the two three five
aspect ratio
the filmic aspect ratio i'm always a fan
of that
um the the the wardrobe itself i think
you can maybe could do like
more of a knit material versus like just
like a bumpy rough
or like a bumpy diffused material i
think could help it out a little bit
but i really like your christmas trees i
think those look really really good
and the way this is going towards this
like center point you get the brightest
point
in the center with the moon and it just
all comes down to here
so i think it's well composed i need to
know the back story
yeah what's the backstory of this is it
like is he like see you later
or is he like yeah i don't know
yeah dead eye duck
that's a really good render it's like a
romance novel
that's intense see that's what i'm
talking about look at the look at the
knit
here on the the wardrobe versus just a
bumpy uh diffuse
it's actually you know a different kind
of bump slash
normal this is well done
this is very well done
i like this a lot very good render
quality the snow looks
nice it's like it looks like it's
glowing almost
um yes that's not bad that's not bad at
all i think this is super solid
it's christmassy in the fact that
there's snow
you know and that's about it so it's not
not the
the harshest christmas christmas vibes
but
i guess it takes place in or around on
you know christmas i went to wonderland
at least
also what little little guy in the
background
it's a wolf something maybe that should
be a reindeer
maybe the 12 wolves of christmas
all right moving on mr ant
commando i don't know um
so you modeled everything dude this is
great
that's great yeah for modeling
everything yourself dude
solid work i love it you got uh
the snowman in there you got the
airplane going um
santa is getting blasted off here um by
some reindeer probably
and a giant old tree dude this is like
some early like runescape looking
like christmas at runescape or something
like that
i dig it man this is fun you got the
snow going and everything
very cool all right we're moving on
copperbot chester copperbot
dang whoa what this is like necro
christmas
dude christmas you didn't ask for
that's intense that's so scary
that is so scary i really like this
the front lit um like flashlight look
it's such a creepy vibe yeah i didn't
even realize that that was probably
probably what was making it so creepy
yeah it's like you just rolled up on
this
in the middle of nowhere yeah
the only thing i think this needs man is
um it looks like it's straight out of a
game
which isn't a bad thing don't think that
is a bad thing uh
it needs a little bit of blur
it's too crisp and it could use a little
bit it looks like you added
green but it looks like low-res green or
low-res noise or something
i think it just needs a little bit of
blur it's a little too
it's a little too sharp um
and i don't know if you're using path
tracing or direct lighting
on this it's hard to tell especially
with like the way you lit your scene
i think another thing too you could use
is maybe a little bit of particles in
the air
just a little bit more fog right here in
the front i think could
could make it look a little nicer
and maybe bring your light source more
towards the camera
camera's point of view because it's
lighting up this random branch here
which
doesn't mean anything in the scene but
it's very hot so you don't your eye is
kind of drawn there for no reason
so you want to keep it center here but
otherwise i think this is awesome
this looks really really good dude
that's rudolph i kind of want to see
like a
blood nose oh a bloody
nose oh totally no that's so good
yeah that's really that's really nice i
like it a lot
this is the scene in the wireframe cool
very nice fetish
christmas tree space station dude they
only bust this out
in like the second half of december
you know like they keep it in storage
until then
um not bad dude not bad at all
i like your material that you used here
for the
for the spaceship
yeah there's like some bump going on
there and some like
techie shapes going on i like that a lot
and you got your lights
now i feel like the lights would be more
of a white
they would saturate to white same for
these guys they wouldn't be so yellow
um so that's definitely something to
watch out for um
[Music]
the displacement on the rock here looks
a little intense that might need to come
down just a bit um
but otherwise you know not bad at all
look up paul chad heason i think that's
his name
he has a lot of really incredible space
renders
that i know you're gonna love um
he is the king of large-scale
space renders um he does such a good job
so definitely check this dude out if
you're looking for inspiration that's so
cool it looks like
uh do you guys still call it kit bashing
yeah in 3d
yeah and he actually uses cinema 4d as
well so this guy
is legit nice oh can i get that that
live chat
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah boom
all right moving on
oliver twist got us with a video
what is that what is that
i like the amazon joke that's pretty
sick
who is that he's doing a jig he's like
i need to see this character model i
know he look he looks like
um earthworm jim yeah like a chubby
earthworm
he gained a few few pounds later in life
that's great dude
um i dig the wait hold on what's that
mounted to the
i'm gonna try and pause it like right
when i started again
okay so those are just like dude did he
kill his reindeer
oh my god mount them is that rudolph
oh no this has got morbid
that's rudolph dude is this shotgun
santa's like
next frame oh man
that's brutal he's he's so happy
because he doesn't need him anymore
amazon killed him he's done with
christmas dude amazon killed his
reindeer
there's so many layers to this video oh
my god
rough dude i'm really mostly surprised
about the fact that he's dancing though
yeah i'm like did he do this like is he
finished with christmas
and he's excited about it somebody says
that's the single ladies dance
oh the single ladies
this is awesome i dig this a lot that's
funny
oliver twist good job man
all right kf hammond what you got
oh my god
wow that's crazy
dude i want to score that that's a
christmas moment
[Music]
man that's really good dang your
animation is
solid animation is one of the hardest
things to do for me
you got incredible surface imperfections
going you're telling a story
with this
oh that's so good the way you animated
the hand too
yeah that's the perfect poop the only
thing i'm missing is the fingerprint
left by the boot because you have all
the good surfaces of
imperfections on this thing thing what
is this an ornament it's an ornament
that's so good
dang my mind's blown dude oh wow
i like that a lot
kf hammond got you in the back of my
mind very nice
all right gt dt
oh man it's just like command center or
is he just watching tv
this is like no no he's on c4d oh
and it's a stream and that's me oh sick
what's it what's the uh
streamer say at the top oh it's photos
are those are your past renders
yeah no it's a past stream when i was it
was my last stream no like up at the top
of the stream this picture oh
are those the contest winners what is
that
no these are pictures i think probably
uh sentimental to the person who
rendered this oh okay cool
gtdt um
[Music]
that's funny oh so there you are on the
bottom yeah
okay so here's the thing um
the tv screen's just oh my god
that's terrifying wait that's the
fireplace and santa's stuck in the
fireplace
ooh time to turn that heat up time to
turn up eight
that's terrifying this looks like deus
ex one yeah totally finished that game
it's so good um he was a good man in the
flesh dude
this is great uh i love the vibe here
you know you got winter time outside
doing its thing
crazy rug dude this rug would cost so
much money yeah it's huge
that's nuts i just bought a rug see i
don't want to think about that
this is fun i like this a lot i like the
little cameo going on here
i would brighten up the tv just a bit i
think the tv would be a bit brighter
um but yeah
i love that the santa in the fireplace
is terrifying
i think if you had the fire going now
that would be the next level but yeah i
like that a lot good work
purple light that is a cupcake
dude look at the fork
it's got nastiness on it that you would
expect to see from
sugary fingers yep surface imperfections
it's what takes your render to the next
level
this is great yeah now
if i looked at this would i think
christmas i don't think so
but it's a solid render and you're using
depth of field very nicely
i like it a lot it draws the attention
right here right where your focus is
i think it's super solid so this is a
beautiful render purple lights i think
right very nice very very nice render i
like it a lot
so oh there's a christmas tree in the
background okay
maybe no those are flowers i can't tell
poinsettias or something
maybe but um
yeah super good render dude tristan
17 christmas rendering hey not bad dude
um those presents look really nice and
the fireplace looks like some
action vfx elements perhaps or some
action movie essentials
it looks really good you can actually
use those elements in 3d
and like have them light your scene
which is it looks like exactly what you
did
or you compt it in after effects
regardless it looks good
i think your brick is a little too thick
and soft
at the same time
the presence a little low poly but no
they're not bad
your your ground looks great you have
your surface imperfections on the
hardwood floor i think that looks
awesome um tree lights look fun
you got disco balls on your tree i like
it not bad at all man not bad i like it
a lot
i feel like the only thing you're
missing
are like cookie crumbs and like
the remainder of santa like going out up
and out you know
like he left the presents and then you
have like cookie crumbs and maybe a
cookie and a plate
eaten or something and then he's gone
and that would add like a little story
element to it or something
but not bad at all i like it
marvelous me 907. what you got
oh my god
dude this is awesome
that's awesome i just wanted more of
that
whoa
that's dude that angle is so good yeah
i just want more of this dude that's
amazing i think my only complaint is he
didn't say it's turbo time when you hit
the button
oh man it's turbo time
so really nice
detail blowing the leaves back with the
smoke
you got a nice shock wave and your your
uh
your simulation here is really nice dude
this shot is so good
your lighting is really nice i think the
only thing that throws me
um is this first camera angle it looks
like he's jumping
in to to frame
but you're missing that like it looks
like he's hopping into it you know
and it's the camera starts orbiting
around him
i would almost want to see like a push
in on him first
um because that'll describe the
character a bit more yeah that second
that third angle is the best
um your second angle is a little too
close to the end of your first angle
it almost looks like it's repeating um
like it was meant to be the first angle
so those are the only things that that
gets me man everything else is
so well done the render quality is great
your animation is great it looks like
it's actually made of like
toys like it's a claymation but this
angle here is so good
santa's coming yeah that hop
in yeah there's like he just like
spawned
yeah it's like he just spawned
ah that's so good i love that yeah it's
super cute
all right that blender guy what you got
all right you got a little christmas
scene here we got santa up in here
looking nice um
so good work on getting this room
together and lighting it i think you did
a good job there
the only thing that's throwing me here
is
uh the tree itself it feels too
um like the leaves are too large
like it's made of large leaves versus a
lot of smaller leaves
so i'm just missing out i'm missing out
on that
element there
um yeah your presence looked nice the
chair looks nice
you got a little picture up here that's
great i love it um you got santa out the
window
i think you might be able to mess around
too with uh
darkening the scene and and letting the
christmas lights and the fireplace light
a little bit more too
but yeah that's that's about all i have
with this one man i think it's good i
i i like what you did and i think you
did a good job putting the room together
all right arjun stark your first
submission congratulations
sweet man you got some fog an exterior
foggy scene going i dig it
you know i love my fog um cool you got a
snowman going
i like your sky now here's the thing
your white levels are clipped
so that your white has turned to gray
which technically would not happen
definitely watch out for that you know
you people will be able to spot that
so that white should be pure white um
you should just use a different
background if you're trying to go for a
more overcast background as opposed to
lowering the white levels
of the white there
yeah the christmas tree is not bad be
nice to see some glow from this guy
i think that could look nice but i do
like your composition i like the way
this house sits here against these trees
which look really really nice
and your snow though your snow it looks
a little bit too reflective like water
i think snow is a bunch of tiny little
reflective uh you know snowy bits
so i think it'd be more matte and look a
bit more sparkly
um like the uh like that
i don't know christmas goddess image the
snow there
a little bit more like that
all right moving on walnut brain
i like that tree sale
all right well it reads and it reads
it's christmas
we've got a tree sale here with some
trees in the background some lights
cool i dig it um
i'm just a bit confused by this like
glass
like fixture here it's interesting
but i think it takes away from
the tree yard or the the you know like
the tree scape you got going back here
um i want to see more trees as opposed
to you know this glass bit i get that
we're at a tree lot
you got the tree sales sign um
i would probably just focus a bit more
on the trees themselves let them go off
into the background
i don't know if the sign is doing much
for me or at least the top bits of this
sign
but other than that i think it's cool i
think you did a really nice job getting
a nice tree model here i think that
looks great
and your fog going off in the background
it looks great so does your lighting
so good job there
all right before christmas boom
i mean what can i say
it's classic and it's well done is that
earth
no shouldn't be no that's just snow
very nice yeah this is cool man i dig
this
classic shout outs
um i don't know if i have anything to
add
i mean it's like it is what it is you
know i think you did a good job of it
nice job posing the characters as well i
like it a lot
toxic wizard good stuff oh this is the
scene
very cool there's a pumpkin in there
somewhere
nah all right
hey god is next
okay all right we got a snowy scene with
one
present and it says for mr yeti
only and i am assuming that this is mr
eddie
mr yeti sorry i think
i think it is maybe maybe that's what
it's supposed to be
i think what you got going on here is
like a cloth sim
a cloak on somebody and it's just hard
to tell what the silhouette is
so you need to maybe more define your
silhouette so that we know what that
is but you got your one present under
the tree that looks nice and you even
have footprints coming up mr yeti looks
like he wears some nice shoes
and he's coming up and maybe that's not
mr yeti who knows
um your background just a little low res
maybe you could find a a higher res
background if you go to google
and you do a image search
you can go to tools and you can or
settings and go to
advanced search and you can search for
an image size
larger than whatever you want to choose
so if you type in snowy mountains and
you want
8 megapixels
then you can get some really large
mountain
backgrounds here you just right click
open image in new tab
and you got like you know the full size
image
going here so that's one way
to find quick backgrounds like that but
good job
nice render thanks for joining
toxic is next it's cozy
very cozy very warm i like it a lot
it's me and me and toxic chilling we got
our
our uh our stockings nice job on the
stocking render i like that a lot
fresh hot cocoa yeah
steaming hot is that a book what is that
i don't know what that is it's like the
outside
of a book yeah um a nice clock with some
candles
a christmas tree i like it a lot it's
very nice
um very similar to one of the to uh
another render we looked at
um this one though i like the render
quality on this one a whole lot i think
maybe you can bring down the highlights
it's just a little bright there
but other than that man i think this is
super solid i really dig it
you think the bag detail on that that's
good stuff
very good stuff toxic
prid pretty dill prit dill
all right so you go in with a little
tilt shift effect your lighting
is very interesting um it reminds me of
a certain time of day like a very
specific time of day
you got santa going going in the back
there just dropping off the presents
i like this it feels like uh you know
like i can touch it like i can reach out
and touch it
so i dig this a lot very nice
very very nice hazelnut spread
let's check this one out that's that's
very classic
super classic christmas really good job
on the candles that looks
great um i feel like the wood is just
missing a little bit of surface
imperfection
i think a little can go a long way but
your lighting is very nice i like the
purple light
off to the right here um it looks like
you have a nice hdri
lightning the scene and a mini little
door
leading to a fun world i i feel
christmas
when i see this for sure dude my mom
totally has these like
little wooden things in the pine the
pine cone decoration
yep super classic i like this a lot
it's very good nice nice render quality
nice composition
whoa cavalry weirdo
what you got
very nice dude this is awesome
um santa just dropped off some gifts to
these sisters the mom and her daughter
something um
and they're waving by you know you got
the santa footprints and the snow down
here
it looks like and that's where the
sleigh took off
really good detail there and you got the
neighbors chilling
she's oblivious no idea that santa just
rolled up
but i like it a lot i like i think this
is another one here they could benefit
from
a little bit of blur just a little blur
to hide these super hard edges here same
here you know
and then some film green i think that
stuff goes a really long way
so definitely keep that in mind on your
next one but i think this is super solid
great job
andy dc we got a nice isometric view
of
downtown somewhere someone rolling up we
got a i don't know how they're driving
i don't know how they're seeing anything
but um i think it's cool hey
good good job getting the snow in the
right places on the road
that's where cars don't drive so i think
that looks really good
um snow on the side of the road is
usually a little dirty
so i think that could be a nice little
detail to add but this feels fun it
feels like a
you know a top-down kind of video game
look that i think could be a lot of fun
so
this is cool um your road though i could
see your road
sitting on top of the road underneath so
you they're
roads are tough you'd want to find some
sort of intersection texture or
something
which is very difficult to come by
i'm trying to think how i would do that
but
yeah that's a tough one you might have
to just do the road as a texture and
then
do the paint lines yourself which would
take a long time
but i think for what it is maybe you
could even have photoshopped that just
content aware fill those out or
something
um but it's not that big of a deal to be
honest i think this is
this looks really cool
cha is fireplace time very nice we got a
fireplace with some leather stockings
um little leaves hanging up here
classic little fireplace very nice
very nice i don't know if i have enough
anything to add to this like it is what
it is you know it looks just looks good
good work thanks for submitting super
solid
got your tree back here very
minimalistic classic
very yeah very i think maybe the
framing's the only thing i'd do
i would just center more center frame on
the fireplace
because i'm not really getting anything
up here there's nothing to see up here
so i'd tilt down
and and zoom in maybe a little bit i
think that'd be my only note
tapi kisotoku
sweet christmas trolley christmas
trolley
going somewhere with presence
in the back i like the lighting inside i
think that's nice good exterior feel
maybe a little bit of snow could help
not that
you would need it but a little bit of
particles in the air
goes a long way um
yeah this is cool you got you know some
christmas lights up in here maybe that's
topo wire as well kind of looks like it
a little bit
um you got your nice space hdri back
here
and the headlights i feel like the
headlights would be a little bit
brighter than the
lights in the van but that's probably a
style choice you want to draw the eye to
the to what's in the van before you draw
to
draw to the headlights so i think that's
really nice i think that's a good job
oh snap did we get a little
adventure gif that's way better
that's super cute dude
that's so good
ah this is a topple yeah
the wobbles dude that is awesome
i love that that tree swipe resetting
the loop or something
yeah i think maybe a little bit of
motion blur could help this but
um i dig this a lot man like a lot
better than just the
image itself really good job with
animation on the car
i love it all right ronin
snow globes another classic yeah super
super classy very nice
some traditional huts would be cool
to live in one of those yeah very nice
um
you got a little some scratches on here
i think that's cool
it's lit from a warm soft warm light
very nice
some scratches on the globe itself
some smudges and stuff
yeah not bad i like it
ronin good work and also casey
we have
this many left
and i know that you're on a time time
frame today i think the only thing
that's going to set me off is if i get
the phone call that we're going to be
there in five minutes
okay all right yeah we're almost through
it's all good probably have like ten
more so
i'm really enjoying this we got another
snow globe
karimi
i like this one a lot dude all this
money
just freaking money dude i like the
geometric take on the christmas tree
yeah me too
i could do without the money but i like
i like everything else about it
yeah the money feels a little out of
place unless it's like a comment on
society
you know and it's just like you know
people just buying stuff all the time
and
it's all about the money definitely feel
the political take on it
um but it doesn't feel
wrong um i see your cookies
and uh very nice wood texture on the
ground here
as well as a snow globe um
[Music]
maybe some lights on the tree could
brighten up the center a little bit to
draw the eye
more to the tree itself to give it a bit
more contrast but
i like it a lot i think it's really nice
karimi good work
rigging tim frickin super
sanimobile dude this thing is awesome i
thought this would be jan
if he was santa oh my god it totally is
it totally is
this is great um
yeah very very nice really cool design
here
did you design this yourself first time
doing this really put a lot into it i
could tell man
yeah it looks great
it looks really really nice um
let's see okay what would we do here
bevel our edges that's the first thing
we want to bevel our edges so that you
catch the light on the edge
you're kind of doing it here but i'm not
really seeing it here
um but man yeah no it's
solid i really like the design i think
it's great i think it's really nice
um what would i do what would i add
maybe a bit of fog i think could
help bring out you know this foreground
a little bit more not that it's blended
into the background but i think it could
just help your lighting just a bit um
[Music]
that's just a personal opinion i could
see your background disappearing just a
little bit maybe you could photoshop
that in
a hair um and i think
also this one could benefit from a
little bit of blur
to get away from that cg look and then a
touch of film grain or touch of noise
just to make it feel more realistic
i think would be really nice but not bad
at all
not bad at all i like it a lot
i wonder where this guy goes day to day
you know
all right
prothomesh
within a day due to some office work
first submission ever
welcome thank you for submitting
sweet yeah this is classic
you know we got a silver tree with some
presents
and a chair i really like that chair
model that looks really good
and some fancy light bulbs up top yeah i
think it just looks really good
i think this looks solid great work
maybe this could benefit from a vignette
i think you could have a vignette around
it to focus it more
on the center of the scene here because
we're not really getting much from the
windows and stuff
something you can just focus the
attention a bit more on the center
with your chair and your christmas tree
i felt very modern
super modern yeah even the interior
design and the lighting and
yeah yeah i really like it fruit juice
fruit juice christmas coming early to
paris
that's cool i really like what you did
here is that
google maps dude
yeah you use google maps 3d view pulled
that
it almost has a paint really look to it
yeah it does and then you got the
surface imperfections going with santa
flying across
i like it a lot it's a little hard to
tell that it's in a snow globe though
just because it's so dark
so that would be my only note it's just
like you know if it's gonna be in a snow
globe
make it a little bit more obvious that
it's in a snow globe
but that that's my only note i really
like it i think it's awesome
same it is interesting how the like that
weird like
low res google maps thing is bringing
that like oil painting
effect to it almost it does yeah it
totally does
that's great all right tinum
that's your clay viewport nodes final
here we go
jeez dang yeah his render quality is
always the best
hitting with those uh with those smudges
very very nice we got a christmas up in
here it's lit
very well and this marble feels super
nice
um merry christmas from town and you got
the uh
the fingerprints on here too it looks
super good
really really nice some scratches on the
side here
yeah that is very very nice
i like that render quality a whole lot
great work as always super solid
all right child renderer what you got
for us
dude look at this santa dude he's ready
for that landing
i know that's great all right just
we'll scroll back up here and make sure
okay we're good
all right so yeah great dude the trees
look really nice
i love those trees and you got santa's
chilling
just having a good old time ready to
take off
um and a snowman yeah so the only thing
here for me would probably just be your
snow and ground texture
look into rd textures that's the letter
r and d real displacement textures they
have some good snow ones
and the displacement looks like it's
breaking your ground plane
because it doesn't have enough polygons
so you're going to need to up the
polygon count of your ground in order to
get that
to look a bit more natural um
your snowman the texture on the snowman
is looping a little bit so you probably
want to
either scale up the snow or mix two
different textures together
in order to get more of a uh a random
look
to your snow but other than that great
work i think it looks fun
dude this like mushroom uh
snow globe like a doorknob
all right i'm gonna grab a swig of water
real quick
it's like an epoxied wood resin yeah
let's see the difference between that
and the table i like it
yeah so it's like the rough rough um
wood and the shiny wood here
yeah very nice classic snow globe with a
house inside
lots of snow it almost looks like uh
styrofoam
flakes in here and then is that santa in
the background i think it is
he's doing something getting presents
going or something
yeah very nice a little bit of christmas
lights going there too
sweet
all right danny rbk with your final
render
another snow globe there's a lot of snow
globes this year
um yeah sitting on the table
it looks like it's just about to be
morning it's a very exciting time
um a little dim this is a little dim
um which isn't the worst you know this
can this certainly
would have its place um
i don't know if i have really too much
else to say about this
yeah it's not bad that's not bad at all
like the fireplace i feel like the
fireplace would just be a little bit
brighter
um but you are exposed down pretty far
so maybe that is natural
but i like the time of day it feels it
does feel like it's the morning and the
kids are about to get up and
get some nice presents delage
all right final render
special thanks to darren winkle one of
our mods
maybe give you some ideas and some tips
this looks cool
i like your lighting it feels very cozy
once again
a good job on the presence here i dig it
got the cloth sim going on the table
yeah very nice
very very nice i think again you know
to get away from that that cg look i
always
will blur it just a touch and add some
film grain or some noise on top it goes
a long way it helps out a lot
i think this is one where it could use
that just a bit
but yeah great work
visual cyber santa okay that's
that's jan yeah that's definitely jim
that's awesome i've been playing a lot
of cyberpunk
so oh you have no no sorry i don't use
complete sentences
uh visual has been playing a lot of
cyberpunk gotcha yeah i got excited i
want to play so bad but it's just not
time yet
it's not time yeah for sure this is
great
look at the cyber cigar dude that is
awesome
it's so dope yeah
that's great i don't have much to say
about that it just
is yeah all right he's sitting on a
crate and wired up
yeah seriously hey i got some stories
kid
the only thing all right here here's the
only thing i would add grunge in the
corners
darken the corners um it'll make the the
floor and the wall blend together
same for back here i'm just seeing like
the detachment of the tiles
so i would just shift that side down um
but i really like that tile texture i
think it's great
perfect texture um
and then yeah there's just a weight
painting thing with the arm right here
just a little bit but you have the
subsurface scattering on the skin which
looks really nice
it's just a good render man super solid
always puts out good stuff
i'll be lost wait did did we do abby
lash already
i don't remember
but it's too dark
it's too dark
it's just too dark you know i see
there's a tree there
but it's too dark turn up lights look
this is your scene there's so much to
see
it looks like forest or snow almost
oh man yeah you gotta turn those lights
that's it
um man how do you pick a winner i know
it's hard
like i know which one gave me the
biggest emotional reaction but i don't
know what you're
you're judging everything on well
there's five there's five winners
so we're gonna judge it off of just
overall render quality
lighting composition um textures
everything as a whole
together and then did you hit the theme
of christmas
so that's what we're going for man
um yeah
how do we do this
did he fix it that quick
oh no it keeps scrolling back up
all right so
let's choose these winners let's start
whittling this down
let's try and pick 10
that we really like
starting with this one here
so i'm going to open up pref
and we're going to start copying these
guys in so
i think this one's cool i like the style
that you went for
um the fact that you can see the
reflection of the bulb is really awesome
i dig this too from willy
so i'm gonna paste this i like that
style it doesn't read christmas though
so that's
that's a thing this is cool background's
a little dark
kind of reads christmas um
this one's not bad this one is not bad
that one's great super funny shout outs
um this one's really really nice really
solid render quality it's just
hard to read christmas
i love this
this one dude necromance christmas yeah
necromancer's christmas is super solid
what do you think about this video
i think it's hilarious but i feel like
there are lights on the trees that would
have taken it to the next step
yeah yeah i feel the same it feels like
christmas because i see the word santa
written on there
for sure it's really well done though i
agreed agreed that's why this was so
difficult
it's very difficult it was super
difficult
um dude this one it's my favorite
yeah i hate to be like no no this this
one
this one is amazing that elicited an
emotional reaction for me
he's got the hanging in the tree the
boop
uh and the little intimate moment
between the couple there
i feel it i feel that my heart yeah i
agree
i agree
[Music]
ah man this one this one i think if it
wasn't for that first to second cut that
feels like the same
scene yeah i think i remember joey doing
a video on rocket jump film school about
how they're talking about die hard cuts
and how
the reason why you can't do certain cuts
and that's what this reminds me of for
sure
i i don't know that science very well
but i feel like he would have something
to say about that
yeah this one this one definitely gets
an honorable mention if it's not a
winner
today because i love this last shot it's
all about this last shot yeah
it's so good that's amazing i feel like
just shot two to shot three
yeah or shot one to shot three yeah even
that
ah that's that's close i'm gonna include
it in our
little like whittle down situation here
i would love to score that movie
yeah that'd be amazing
no hard feelings everybody
no hard feelings
[Music]
express vibes on it yeah
dude this is the trolley yeah yeah it's
really good
it's rendered well
look hold on it says look closely
maybe that's the money reference
probably
that's well done yeah just render alone
i think it's pretty well done but yeah
dude rigging tim man
like that's shout outs for for putting
this together
that's that's a good time
render quality is really nice on this
one
i like the fact that you use google maps
there you go that's beautiful very well
lit
very well done
cyber santa is great
and that's it so it comes down it comes
down to these guys
um
so how do we do this i do not envy you
you want no part of this we just got to
do it i might have to ask
i can help if you want and you if i make
a bad decision you can tell me why i'm
wrong
all right i think i think kf
hammond definitely wins
with this animation here that's
absolutely incredible
i everything about this is amazing i
think kf hammond is a winner
congratulations you're a winner this
year um on the last live stream the last
challenge
you get the uh the the the challenge
winner role
throughout the year throughout the rest
of the year i'll see you in
2021. okay um
ones that don't read is christmas this
one
does not read his christmas this does
not read his christmas
willys does not read his christmas i
know it's so well both of them are so
well done
but they're so good yeah they're super
good um
so i feel bad um
but the theme was christmas the theme
it's like the notes you get from
producers you do something really well
and you're proud of and it's technically
really good
but if it's not on brief yeah by a
millimeter
you're gonna get a note yeah but good
work guys
i love your i love your work it's like a
nordic postcard i love it
yeah it's so good it looks like a magic
card
okay so these guys i'll move you off to
the side here
um
ones ones that barely read his christmas
they all read as christmas yeah they all
read his christmas okay
like ones i like ones i really like out
of all these i like this one a lot i
like this one a lot
this one i like a lot this one i like a
lot
um
yeah that's kind of that's kind of it
like
this one is great i love the colors um
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with it there's nothing wrong with it at
all
i think it's really well done um
i think these just have a special little
flair a little special extra thing
obviously cyber santa is awesome this
the fact that this is a video
and i love the atmosphere is great this
one too
is a is a really nice take on uh
you know evil santa evil santa claus is
like is super great
but this one's really good too god dang
it
so we've already split ways now in
favorites really
yeah this one this one is really fun
it is and i think this gets an honorable
shout out an
honorable mention i love the animation
um it's just the way it's cut you know
uh it was a bit jarring but that last
that last shot is so good yeah i would
say don't abandon it give it another
shot
okay something about it i'm not you i'm
not like the person who made it
yeah for sure yeah like just spend that
little bit of extra couple hours
on it to see what would make it because
god it's so good
it's just it's missing something that i
don't know how to tell you how to fix
or alter um let's let's do
let's do tournament bracket we're just
going to do versus
and we'll just see who goes to the next
level
you know what i mean so we're going to
compete
wow you're putting some of these that
are difficult yeah hold on this has to
be
i think your left one is good i can
compete all those
i have an answer for all of those okay
all right so between
actually it's easy to answer too if you
want just one single answer
what's your one single answer everything
on the right yeah
yeah with this one i feel like this one
this one gets it it's just a bit better
with the render quality and everything
um i think it's just the lighting and
the rendering on
on on this santa here the design is
fantastic though
but it it does read more as christmas
though like
we definitely have santa up here oh god
dang it i know it's difficult
but yeah i like i think overall quality
i dig
paris a little bit better um
snow globe versus christmas time i'm
digging the snow globe because the
render quality is just really really
nice
i like it a bit better um and it has a
cool
little story going on here inside of the
snow globe
now with these two there's just a bit
more going on with the one on the right
the one left is cool um it's a nice
little like thumbnail
um it's just this one has more going on
i think it's mean it's just a pure
composition choice
yeah someone told me on the picture on
the left was a renderer i was like what
for real yeah it gets really really well
done it's super good
and then with these um i think this one
they both read as christmas um
but the one on the left
man
it's so difficult
there's a story there's certainly a
story but with this one
it's more of a unique story
you have santa blasting off and
this last shot just makes me laugh so
hard yeah i really do love it
um so i think i'll have to go with the
uh
the different one here so yeah feeling
everything on the right
it's good work to you guys congrats to
making it this far
now between these which ones do we pair
up
i think at this point i have to just let
you take the reins because this is
starting to come down to subjective
opinion
at this point dang it's like i i really
like the necromancer one as far as like
the idea
like i think it's really funny and also
really well done
but as far as render quality goes i feel
like maybe all the other ones are just
like a slight step ahead
for sure um though it is not all about
render quality
right it looks good i think it looks
great i do too especially that right
side
yeah okay um winners for sure
um visual i like cyber santa
same so you're a winner congrats
and i'm pretty sure that's visual pretty
sure
um we can we can figure out the names in
a second
but i dig cyber santa a lot um
i also really dig this animation
with the car driving through um
it feels i like the feeling it gives me
for sure
between these two i think only one snow
globe can win
i know which one i like the most
i like everything about like all these i
really like the lighting in this one the
like soft
warm glowy light i love it it's just
hard to tell it's in a snow globe
um and it's a little too dark on the
outsides i feel like
and also the framing it feels off-framed
like it
for me it needs to be center framed
these two
are center framed i really like the
lighting on this one
um but i think framing wise i enjoy
this one the most this one feels warm
and i'm also getting a bit of a story
from this one too because of the door
that's open on the inside there's a bit
of intrigue there
so i think i have to go with this one
here for the snow globes
even though this one i think looks the
nicest
this one's hitting on all cylinders yeah
you pretty much took the words right out
of my mouth
all right cool that's difficult too
because that town one is really really
well done
i know all right so
killing your babies i know this is
difficult how's the chat doing
so i'm gonna check the link in the
submission channel
what do i what do i need to check soto
uh
check the link in the submission channel
oh oh sick
wow
i kind of like that we didn't know that
already but he still
yeah no that's really cool um i mean
even though he won
um he even had more to it
where he's got you know santa's helper
working on the arm
that's awesome that's legit yeah
that's next level for sure
you just missed the film grain i think
did you have i think you have film green
over your image i can't tell
it looks like the person that's film
green was that just render noise i'm not
sure at this point but
not that you missed anything but anyway
back to it
that's amazing
okay so i like this one
back to these ones here um
so difficult i really like the bus i'm
going with the bus the bus is a winner
um i really like the vibe i like the
feeling and i like the lighting
i like everything about it uh
specifically the the video version of it
i really really dig the video version of
it um
big fan of it so shout outs to the bus
two more two more winners um
you got evil santa which is great
the snow globe i think this snow globe
hmm
there's only one thing i don't like
about that one this one yeah well
there's just no
tiny gripe there's no story you know
like there's not really any story
um that's the only thing i'm getting you
know like there's a fireplace
and it's a scene but it's lacking story
uh the cup i think can be moved over to
the left just a bit
so i can see because the the cup its
silhouette in the smoke
uh gets obscured by the the present here
so it's getting blended into itself
but what were you gonna say mine's just
an interior design thing
uh you don't light a christmas tree like
that
one single strand of lights and you have
like lights really close to the
inside of the pole so you have the
inside illumination and then you do a
full
couple strands around the outside so you
get uh depth of field of illumination
yeah um a lot of the trees had lighting
like that i noticed
it was all single light like that sorry
i'm a little bit christmas obsessive
compulsive
it's beautiful i love how cozy it is
yeah it's a very cozy scene i dig it for
sure that's like if somebody told me to
find something to complain about
that's that's what i would complain
about
oh man between these four i have to
choose two
i'm getting story from these two
um this one just makes me laugh a lot
yeah this one really makes me laugh
this one is a nice cozy setting that i
dig
um god dang i feel like i have to just
make a decision here
it's like in the office whenever uh she
tells michael to just
tell him right then he's like uh this
one yeah and he was like i don't wanna
be with jan
yep yeah that's what you gotta do
demon santa you win
i really like demon santa
and uh this one is amazing
i'm just missing the edit the edit i'm
sorry the first two shots
um it was a little like you spawned in
i think if you would have chosen the
angles a little bit differently
the last one is just so good but it's
just the end of it
it's not the full thing so good work
um i like the reason and the reason i
chose demon santa is because it's
different it's different that's not
cliche
i think a lot of a lot of my decisions
go into stuff that
i've seen something a million times
before and you get tired of it
so i want to see something new and for
me demon santa is something new
and it has story to it and it's well
rendered
so and it's christmas so it's hitting on
all the cylinders so
both of these hit christmas this one has
a bit more story
the render quality i think is equal on
both of these
the lighting is great on both of these i
really dig the lighting on this one
but i think if we're going for all
cylinders
this one gives me christmas it gives me
story lighting composition render
quality so
i think that's going to be the winner
and that's it
we got our five winners right here y'all
boom congratulations
and shout outs to everyone here who made
it to this step because
these are all super solid renders um and
this was
very very very difficult to choose
uh to choose these here so good work
guys
and uh that was a lot of fun i hope you
guys learned something
on this journey uh i hope you guys
learned something this year
watching all these videos and uh thanks
casey for joining me on this dude yeah
man i appreciate it
yeah i'm excited to get back to that um
but guys merry christmas the winners
will be posted in the discord server
um under the weekly challenge winners
and
you know we could do another challenge
but i just wouldn't be able
to you know to
to judge the challenge until i come back
in january
so we could do that we could have a
three week long challenge if you guys
want
um i'll i usually leave it up to the
chat
so um maybe it's just any old render
maybe it's whatever you guys want to
work on
maybe it's more of a loose theme i don't
know we can figure that out in a second
um but congrats to our winners once
again to our five winners right here you
guys are awesome
i have to figure out how to get the last
stream back dude i hope it didn't
disappear
that's really bumming me out
all right let me save this
here so i memorize boom those are our
winners
and that's about it y'all
i think i'll just be chilling for
another three minutes here with casey
if you have any questions for us we'll
answer um otherwise
you guys are awesome thanks for watching
thanks for joining
i hope i can find that stream dude yeah
hopefully
next challenge theme vacant surrender
album art
dude so specific yeah it'd be like it'd
be so sad though because you were like
we spent this time on this thing and we
really like it and
and all honestly we've probably spent
what three hours
because i came over here we did a little
bit of pre-work and then i came here
today
and we've done the majority of the work
for sure yeah and then these people
get four weeks to put together an album
art
i feel like that's like unfair
nah there's no there's none of that all
right we're gonna render this out
um we can add anything i'll i'll do
um a z depth pass
let's see octane render render passes
enable
we want to get that z depth pass
going so we can adjust the like
oh that's so thin yeah like right there
and then you can get different passes
too
so i went right back into tutorial mode
diffuse direct you know so you can bring
out some highlights maybe
later on in our render um
then you do that and put them in
photoshop on top of each other and do
like burn and stuff
yeah yeah yeah so you have all the
different layers and you can like mess
with the
mess with all that stuff you can do the
volume you should hire casey for reading
chat
i'm good i guess he's got better things
to do
yeah i'll get all that stuff set up when
i when i can focus but yeah those are
your render passes and octane you gotta
do a little
box up there um
all right you get that sss on the skin
subsurface scattering it's like when you
shine a light through your finger
that's funny i thought they were making
a devil may cry joke oh i got you
because sss is the most stylish rank you
can get
during oh really yeah triple s smoking
sexy style
really yeah that's funny that's awesome
um so do you guys want to do a challenge
over uh over christmas or do you want to
meet back up next year and do a
challenge you guys want to work on
something for three weeks while we're
gone
i'm happy to do that if you want
what about an image that matches a piece
of casey's music well we've done that
twice now
because i did music for your your images
or at least their chats images
yeah and then and now you're doing one
for me i feel like that's a little too
much of the same
what if we just did album art um
just general album art or do they want
to do an album art for like
go to check out casey's music and pick
it pick an album or something
i don't know what do you think
dang that's difficult it would be fun
one day maybe to just throw them a song
that i never plan on releasing
just to see what they would come up with
or maybe just have one ready in the
future and see what they do
a musical prompt theme with album art
maybe maybe we wait on that one and we
like do something
yeah where it's like you just have like
a little like diddly and you make album
art for the diddly sure
yeah okay so we'll do that we'll do that
uh
maybe next year um but an existing song
would be difficult too because the
allure to look at the album art that
already exists would be too strong
100 yeah 100
um hmm
did you do something with new year's
resolutions is that a thing that you can
do
a visual aid of
sounds difficult this does sound
difficult yeah it does sound very
difficult
um i mean it could just be album art and
you just make up
whatever you guys want pick your own
music
what do you guys think what do you guys
think if we did album art we can always
come back to it with a specific piece of
music
but if the theme was album art
um and you could just pick whatever song
you want
and the idea would be not to copy
existing album art but to listen to a
song and make art that
you think of when you listen to that
music you'd have to post the song you
made album art for
and then your render based off of what
you saw in your head when you listened
to the music
um i think that could be fun just any
any like general song that you want
and then maybe next year we can do one
where like we pick a specific song
and make album art to a specific song or
something it seems pretty split in chat
some people are like yeah album or some
people like nah choose a theme a theme
yeah let casey pick any song and we can
do that that's too hard
20 20 recap oh my god that would be so
depressing
all right i'm leaving it to you guys
what do you want keep dropping ideas in
the chat here
is there any hot ideas that didn't
happen in the past
no we usually pick it like right here
dreams
there's some of the dream theater album
art that's kind of dream like
things that are like suspended like
there's an elephant over here but then
there's a ladder leaning against a
matte painting of a drop back sky or
something like it makes no sense
i feel like i see it i feel like i've
seen that yeah
youtube rewind horror
could be fun um
what's something what's a tangent of
christmas new years
yeah um
dang this is hard i know how do you guys
do this you guys do this every week or
a month every week that's nuts every
single week
winter and snow we kind of did winter in
snow you know
yeah the postcard would win yeah the the
magic card
corridor how would you corridor theme
something
dreams someone's back to dreams again
human 3d model
you got done pets animal i thought
that'd be really difficult for rendering
it would be unless you just downloaded a
model
um
space lovecraftian horror corona
cyberpunk
those are all difficult a lot of random
things i'm brain dead
yeah this is what you get when you
stream every every single week
because you kind of kind of did
cyberpunk-ish right you said you all did
a neon themed one
we did neon i see like a neon downtown
city
yeah no totally we did we did that
something offered to christmas so mr
zombie santa can do something else again
ice or zombies what about horror
just horror what did you guys do for
halloween halloween
what did we do for halloween
what did we do for halloween i don't
remember do we do like pumpkins or
something
um
for halloween
i don't know if we did anything there's
no way we didn't do a halloween themed
episode
did we not do halloween's my favorite
maybe this was no this was movie still
walk cycle still life
thanksgiving dude we screamed to not do
a halloween challenge this year
what are we doing you guys skipped
halloween it's like my favorite house
let's just see what chat's blowing up
with cause maybe they're like no we did
it
let's do a horror one what do you guys
think i was thinking no horror because
it was like
we just did that probably right but
yeah that sounds great yeah i think
horror would be really fun
that's a really good chance to play with
lighting and texture um
it could be super cool
i don't want to scare myself yeah i mean
you're opening up your
presents and spending time with your
family in warm cozy moments and you're
just upstairs rendering blood splatter
yeah tammy what's wrong
mom get out of my room um let's do
horror guys let's make it let's make it
horror
um i know it's christmas but we totally
missed halloween we totally just did a
christmas one
let's do horror whatever that means to
you spooky lighting whatever the heck
willy i know you don't want to do it i
mean you don't have to do it
um you can make it i know you have a
really cool style you can make it fit in
your style
um oh also guys totally forgot the
winners of this
uh of the freaking
the winners this week of the christmas
theme totally get
my surface imperfection pack as well as
my hdri pack
casey i'm gonna show you what i've been
doing
i almost dabbed when you said that i'm
glad i didn't
i've been working on these surface
imperfections
um that make your models look like
dirty and scratched oh right yeah i saw
a little bit this last time i was here
this is pretty sick
so this is like dust um and this comes
out next week guys i'll be selling this
thing next week with my surface
imperfection video
teaching you how to make them yourself
we got dust wipes
different kind of dusty elements here
these are all 16k
i'm sorry not 16k that'd be crazy
they're all 4k 16 bits so they have a
lot of data built in
you can push and pull the contrast of
these to reveal
information that you actually can't see
with your naked eye right now you can
actually raise the exposure
this is all dust which i did like
shaking my head
and like pull like shaking my beanie
over uh
like a like an ipad screen basically
yeah nice
um so we have a bunch of little dust
elements like this we got footprints
here which is one that i like never come
across for the floor
that you can like dirty up a floor with
some footprints we got scratches
some freaking grungy scratches
um this one is like smudges
on like a laptop screen or something or
just a monitor
um somebody's about to turn those into
some blood smudges
absolutely yep so we've got some good
ones here
um and then these are specifically for
the phone so you'll lay these over your
phone
in 3d to give it like a phone wipe so
you can see you know you're checking
your notifications swipe up
swipe left swipe right that kind of
stuff
um you thought it was like a heat map
for where you touch your phone the most
yeah yeah exactly that's funny um
visual yo dude thank you for the super
chat
i appreciate you man um
oh visuals donating his to a runner-up
of my choice
it's an awesome community and i love
seeing all the all the great work
keep it up merry christmas um
that's very nice of you that's very very
kind um
yeah so i'll i'll pass it on to one of
the runner-ups here
that i'll decide here once we once we
close off the stream
but thank you so much visual thanks
thanks to everyone sticking around this
whole year it's been awesome
um but yeah this service imperfection
pack comes out next week
i'll be selling it um for it's gonna be
affordable i'm not gonna make it too
crazy
but yeah we got you know dirt wipes and
water spots and all that fun stuff so
it's gonna be a good time
all you guys who just won you guys are
gonna get this plus my hdri pack so
shout outs much thanks the theme's
horror
you have three weeks to work on it um
look out for the
surface imperfection video next week
it's gonna be awesome
y'all are awesome and uh casey do you
have any other final words or anything
no thanks for being so cool and let me
join you guys stream appreciate it merry
christmas
merry christmas guys i'll see you on the
discord
throughout vacation maybe i need a break
but uh yeah thanks everything guys see
you soon
peace